Dark Souls 3 has been out a while
And you might that you know everything about it, but
Don't underestimate the depth of what this community can discover
That sound you heard at the start
That was a voice clip from the Dancer's opening cutscene
But reversed
And only less than a week ago, reddit user Sentuh
Noticed that reversing the Dancer's soundclips revealed their haunting original sound
Honestly, I'm surprised they didn't use these sounds instead
Next, there are two versions of the Handmaiden in the two variations of Firelink Shrine
One in our enlightened Shrine, and another in the dark Shrine
Which is connected to the rest of the overworld.
And the question is:
Are they the same person? And if they are
Is one in the past, and another in the present?
Well if you talk to the Untended Graves' Handmaiden
Before you talk to our one,
Then our Handmaiden recognizes us, and
Gives a tiny bit of unique dialogue at the start:
So this makes it clear that they're the same person, right
And it also lends credit to the theory that the darkened Shrine appears in the past.
Because she recognizes us.
The shrines are intriguing, and there is a lot more to say
So I'll try to make a video on this area soon.
The earliest mention I found of this is on integ3r's Youtube channel
So credit to him for recording it for sure.
One thing sold by the Handmaiden is the Budding Green Blossom
Which becomes available for ten souls
When you get to the part of Sirris' quest line
Where she goes to kill Hodrick
The interesting thing isn't that it's ten souls
It's that it has an extra sentence in its description that
All the others don't have.
It reads:
"Good-bye, dear Grandmother."
"I will visit Grandfather, in the Pit of Hollows."
And if you look closely, you'll see that these flowers
Are tied with some string, like a bouquet
This might become a knowledge at this point
But I came across this discovery when JakMon777
Twitted the hidden sentence at me and
I couldn't find it in any description I looked at.
Until I looked on the Fextralife Wiki and it had all the information there
So does this make the Handmaiden the grandmother in the description?
Or was this bouquet something that the Handmaiden
Stripped from a grave outside the Shrine?
She does have a habit of accumulating armour sets from corpses after all
For number 4, I loved the discussion that came from the thread made by EtherMoth and Doffymom
Who put forward that each of the unkindled NPCs in Dark Souls 3
Have a link to a Lord of Cinder.
Anri to Aldrich
Siegward to Yhorm and
Hawkwood to his Legion.
We've talked before about how it's an Unkindled's duty
To place the cinders of Lords upon their thrones, and
Each unkindled is somehow invested in the death
Of their corresponding Lords.
The fourth Lord, of course, are the twin Princes, and
It's not too far-fetched to think that we
Are their corresponding Unkindled.
along with the others as
Those with the highest chance to uphold their duty
And bring the Lords we're associated with to their thrones
You should really check out the discussion going on in the link in the description, because
There is a lot more to be said on this topic
I think it's an awesome discovery
Also, in Firelink Shrine
Have you ever had the Firekeeper turn away from you?
This happens if you wear the Untrue Dark Ring
Or the Untrue White Ring
Which are rings that reference the deeply detested Hollows of Londor
So, is she turning away from you in disgust?
This was first posted about by SaviorG and then again by sciritai6 with more proof
I tested it too and I could never get the Firekeeper to turn away
Without the ring on and without being hollowed
So it's undeniable I think that
This turn has something to do with the rings and
Perhaps with the Hollows of Londor as well right?
So let me know if she exhibits this exact same behaviour for you guys as well
It would be good to get some more tests out there I think
Because some people have been reporting that
She turns away without the rings on for them
But I could never get her to do it without the rings
6 is probably the biggest long shot on the list but
I still think it has merit to it
Three months ago, KronosTrinity pointed out that
The Shrine's Handmaiden has unique dialogue
For the Dreamchaser's ashes
Which are the ashes that you find atop Farron Keep
Behind the illusory wall
And he or she also points out that
The hand in these ashes clutches a pendant
In Dark Souls 1, finding meaning for this pendant starting item became
This long running challenge and then joke
Of the series because
The series' creator Miyazaki mentioned that
He'd like to select the pendant himself, personally
And later he admitted that the pendant was a bit of a prank
Intended to keep the players guessing at its purpose
For, in this game full of secrets
How could such a thing be meaningless right?
So is the Handmaiden poking fun at
Whoever's clutching the pendant?
Are the creators making fun of us
For clinging to these lofty dreams?
Number 7 is a relatively recent discovery for how amazing it is
So around three weeks ago, user Skarekrow13 over on the Fextralife forum
Posted this exhaustive breakdown of how he
Deciphered the runes upon the titanite slabs in Dark Souls 3
And his interpretation is that every symbol line
Describes a different historical age in the series
He roughly translates line 1 to:
Skarekrow stresses that there is a great deal of
Personal bias involved in anyone's interpretation
Of these runes and these symbols
Including his own bias, so
I really really encourage you to read his article on the topic, because
Your interpretation serves a really big part in this as well
It's crazy that this could go undiscovered for so long
Moving on, did you ever do a visceral attack on one of the Pontiff's beasts, but
Not finish it off when it was vulnerable?
The first post I can find on this is by GNLink34
Whose post got a ton of attention about three months ago
To me, more than anything, this helps cement Pontiff's Sulyvahn's character
Because he was the one responsible for these beings becoming this way
He was a tyrant, a man with twisted morals who
Transformed his own men into these beasts
And yet it's clear that some of these beasts' humanity
It still remains, and they are either begging for mercy here
Or they're praying in desperation
The next thing is that Anri has unique piece of dialogue and interaction
If you execute Horace while they're along the Path of Sacrifices
And finally, something I wish I knew in my last video
The comment section caught me up on this
So there is this statue in Lower Lothric
And user Hoototo points out the links between it and Pontiff Sulyvahn
First, this statue holds the Profaned Great Sword
Which is a weapon wielded by Sulyvahn, and
This weapon also references him
When he was still a young sorcerer
Second, the bracelet that the statue has is
The same as the bracelet on Sulyvahn's right arm
And you might think, you know, okay
A few reused assets, big deal, From does this all the time
But this statue linking Lothric and young Sulyvahn
It's a huge deal
If you watched the Angels video
Then you'll know that I talked a lot about how
The Lothric bloodline and the sorcerers of the Grand Archives
Rose together. They were very close
And I also said that
The first of the Scholars played a part in convincing
The young Lord Lothric against the linking of the flame
And the Pontiff is this character that
Really does go against the linking of the flame as well
So he's a huge candidate for being the First of the Scholars
This character who convinced Lothric not to link the fire
And additionally, the Pontiff's gear looks
A lot like the candlestick Scholars of the Grand Archives
So it seems pretty clear to me
That Sulyvahn might be responsible for convincing Lothric not to link the fire.
And that he might be very much responsible
For the defection of the Deacons of the Deep away
From the Way of White
For the fall of Lothric's bloodline and
Basically for most of the events in the game
Before you go, I've got one thing to ask of you guy
And it's not to like this video, it's instead
To go and send some love and some friendly mail
To the people I featured in this video
To read their contributions and
To continue supporting the incredible discoveries of everybody in this community
Because I'm just happy I can be a platform
To display and discuss some of this stuff
Also, why the fuck is there a crab in the ball??